it's spooky home school season
and today we're working on a geology unit study
to make this unit study even more interesting
I'm gonna use a Declan's mining bucket
these things are so freaking cool
my kids absolutely love them
this one is their raw rocks bucket
and I think this one might be my favourite cause it's just so basic
and it's perfect for this geology lesson
my son is so excited for this lesson today
also check out their store
because they have some really cute Halloween buckets right now
and I still wish I got one of those instead
all their buckets come with their own field guide
and this is so cute they're a family company
I love support in this company
love their buckets
if you have a kid that is into geology right now or just loves rocks
I would highly suggest this for a birthday or Christmas present
it's absolutely amazing click the link in this video to grab yours today